this might be an interesting segue to
the very rice thing with chocolate oh
let's pull up the barry weiss thing yeah
let's talk all about how the corrupt
media operates
daily mail reports
barry weiss reveals new york times
editors wanted to check with chuck
schumer before running an op-ed by
republican tim scott about his police
reform bill after george floyd's murder
what
it's amazing tim scott had a police
reform bill and the democrats said no to
it and the new york times wanted to
check with chuck schumer that's what
barry white says former nyt opinion
editor barry weiss told senator tim
scott on wednesday about an internal
discussion around his op-ed
scott's article was the subject of an
internal debate excuse me why said and
one of the senior editors questioned
whether republicans cared about minority
rights the new york times denied her
account saying the new york times
opinion never seeks outside approval or
consultation whether to publish guest
opinion essays i'm going to call bs in
the new york times having worked for
many of these you know organizations
this is the exact kind of stuff you see
yep absolute corruption
yep
and also
barry is
actually trustworthy
yeah she's been doing pretty well with
her sub stack yeah i trust her way more
i think she gets some things wrong you
know but that's fine i think she's more
trustworthy in her assessments than the
new york times and she's also just
telling
a rendition of something she witnessed
she's credible yes incredible witness
um she has no reason to make this up
she's you know she's moved on from the
new york times she's very successful
she's making more money than she did
well the reason she could make it up is
to get back at them for something
but why not say it sooner
i mean i don't know i'm not paralyzed
but
i think more people should speak out
about the stuff sooner rather than later
and she mentioned it was in 2020 but
she's been independent for a long time
so why not say something sooner
i don't know it's quite the hat trick
gonna have to have her on the show and
ask her about it it's topical and i'm
not saying that she's lying i'm just
saying that you know i wonder too if
they're sorry oh no go for it there's a
lot of stuff she could probably say you
can't you know you if you publish your
memoir the day you leave or you know in
2020 stuff is gonna get missed like in
some ways
i didn't read this article so i can't
say what the context like
where she brought it up um
but
i have a conversation with tim scott
right and i
feel like
there was a lot of stuff she could tell
us about what happened there
if she doled it all out once i think it
would get kind of lost the impact would
get lost yeah i mean i from from the
reporting she was having a conversation
with tim scott and she said
i i don't know if you know this but
there this is what happened and so i
think it was sort of a natural thing i
mean it makes me wonder what other
stories she has under her hat and i
think that there was a lot of i mean she
was i think she should have sued the new
york times personally because it was you
know workplace bullying and and
intimidation and everything and
um i think that there was some stuff
that happened that in the moment she
felt like she was crazy because every
everyone was like well yes of course we
talked to chuck schumer about it we just
wanted to clear it and she's kind of
like but why do we clearly chuck schumer
what and i think
it's you know you're as you exit the
cult she's kind of like i was really
messed up wasn't it and she's kind of
having that realization and and sort of
unpacking her own experience because i
think she was so abused
in german you ever see uh bulworth that
movie no you ever see it with no kevin
kahn no no that's uh what's it warm
beatty i think it's the one where uh the
politician the senator is like super
depressed and wants to kill himself so
then he just starts telling the truth
and like he doesn't care anymore but
then he like decides he wants to live or
whatever
he like goes up on stage at a black
church and they're like why didn't you
deliver this bill and he's like because
we got your vote we don't care the
moment you went voted for us we stopped
caring about what you thought and then
they were like what and then people
ended up really liking it
i think that with you know people like
barry weiss
she's probably sitting on a whole bunch
of other stuff and i'd say like come on
like of course she is that she's not
going to talk about because she's
probably scared about what will happen
if she if he challenges the machine and
i mean if you were in a cult you
participated in the cult right so there
are there's probably stuff that she's i
could imagine not proud of or not ready
to talk about her involvement in right
and i
you know i don't necessarily hold that
against her it's a complicated thing to
come out of something or to disassociate
or something from an ideology you've
been wrapped up in for a long time but
some of her stories you know she's in
the rooms for a reason she's involved
with the organization so i mean she was
a junior staffer i mean i think i think
that um
i think it's it's hard to
to be in that moment i mean she was she
was in that newsroom and everyone around
her was just
they i mean they wanted to throttle her
and i i can't imagine what that feels
like to go
day after day somewhere where everyone
hates you and one misstep like you
didn't wash your hands after you left
the bathroom can be become like a viral
twitter thread of your colleague who's
sitting like our distance apart from
each other
um but i don't know if she's scared of
them anymore i think that she's burned
that bridge and she's not looking back
didn't uh
someone who works with her write that
terrible article about jordan peterson
and enforced monogamy so you wondered
like to what degree they were
participating and they decided like i
don't want to do this i don't i don't
necessarily trust a lot of people
especially if it takes them two years to
come out and be like oh by the way this
like crazy this really crazy thing
happened it's like that's that's the
kind of thing where i'd be like i want
to quit and in fact when i worked for
fusion and they started doing this stuff
i tried quitting but i was under
contract so instead i just stopped
participating in in their in their bs
system
and then immediately started telling
everybody about it just like screaming
it and uh they really don't like it
the fact that they would stealth edit
articles and told me not to report on
the new york times doing stealth editing
because they would get exposed for doing
it as well and i was like i'm gonna tell
everybody are you nuts you mean you're
violating journalistic standards you
think i'm gonna keep that a secret bro
i'm a journalist like my goal is to
inform people not
not be like a tribalist for some
corporation you think i care about
fusion's bottom line like i'm here to
tell people what's going on in the world
so when the president of that company
said we're here to side with the
audience in reference to
how we handle bias and perspective
basically said you know millennial or he
said young people are progressive so
that's who we're going to side with
we're going to side with them
when i said if if that does that mean
that does that mean if there's a
fact-based news story that would offend
our audience we don't report it he says
yeah i think that's fair
and i immediately told everybody
and then he denied it and i'm like
whatever man of course they're gonna
deny it like these people aren't
journalists they're businessmen who are
like how do we make money
say what people want to hear
there are a lot of people working for
these organizations who know it james
o'keefe the the man is doing the lord's
work when he exposed cnn and you can see
these people saying like we used to do
the news now we don't those people
aren't speaking out those people aren't
coming out and explaining everybody
they're lying to their faces but behind
the scenes they're saying in private it
takes a special kind of person to know
you are engaged in operating an evil
machine that destroys this country but
be like
i need the paycheck
i don't know if that's it i mean i think
for i like speaking up for barry
like i'm not going to speak up for the
rest of them but
i mean she and i had this experience as
someone who wrote for berry for the new
york times she fought really hard to get
sanity on the pages and to get
different perspectives published in the
times that wouldn't have otherwise been
there and i think that she swallowed
a lot of stuff for a long time that made
her deeply uncomfortable because she
felt like it was for the greater good
and i think she got to a point where she
realized
that is that is a calculus that no
longer
it's not it's not equaling out anymore
i'm not doing more good inside the
machine than outside the machine i think
that that's when she left but she fought
very hard for a while to to operate
under you know behind enemy lines and i
think it just got to the point where she
realized like it just wasn't tangible
anymore and she wasn't having enough of
an impact to justify
not just you know being part of the
machine but also just the mental health
strain that she was under and the
assault that she was under by all of her
colleagues but yeah i respect her for
saying as long as she did but i mean
there's people at cnn that james o'keefe
exposed yeah they're like talking to
this hidden camera saying
look at all the really awful things this
company does and they're still there
and they just they know
that's the craziest thing to me these
people are caught on camera talking
about how they know they're involved in
malfeasance but i think they think it's
for the greater good no no no no no
they're telling hidden camera like cnn
is destroying everything
and we are helping them and then they're
like but we're gonna stay but i think
they think ultimately it is for the
greater good because they are
setting a narrative
that how do they think is important
how do you change
i'm i no i'm saying
undercover camera exposes they're
admitting they're doing wrong are you
saying it's sort of like they're
accelerationists they're like look we
got to burn it down and we are willing
to bring it down this way
no like there's one famous guy who's
like sitting in a chair and he's like or
one of the famous exposes a guy who's
like we used to go out and report the
news man now all we do is just complain
about trump and just try and drive this
this this thing and he thinks that's a
good but i think they think that's a
good thing he's complaining about it and
he said he hates being i think it's
annoying but ultimately i think that
given the choice between straight
news reporting and trashing trump they
don't but this is a guy who's saying he
wished they did real news reporting i
think he says he i think he wants to say
that i think he but obviously he doesn't
actually believe it or he would laugh
right well that's einstein said that's
the definition of an insanity is when
you keep doing the same thing expecting
a different result and these people that
are staying there expecting it if they
really are they believe it's going to
get better by staying there they're
insane according to einstein it's a very
general term but it could be a form of
insanity i don't think that's a pass to
do it i could be an explanation of why i
agree with you in that regard a lot of
people say they want things but they
really don't like they either don't want
it or they actually just don't care
enough to pursue
going after something
so maybe for a lot of these people they
just think
you know this cnn's culture behind the
scenes is to rag on the company for
being garbage but no one really cares i
mean but also where do they go like in
their industry i mean it's it's kind of
like you know
great sort of all the complaints that
you hear about parents of kids in
private schools and they complain and
they complain and complain i'm thinking
of the sort of the folks that are
talking about like the wokeness in in
all these private schools
and
they stay because it's the pinnacle of
achievement and i think that these
people at cnn this is the pinnacle of
professional achievement in their
industry and so where do they go what do
they do there's no next step and so
they're just sort of stuck in a holding
pattern because they care more about
their job
sort of that's my point though they care
more about their their
personal lives and they do about the
system they're participating in yeah i
mean not just but i don't think it's
just the paycheck i think it's also
their pride i think it's
i think it's a lot of their sort of
self-identity and
they would rather be
you know it's probably why they demoted
taylor lorenz the behind the scenes uh
scuttlebutt was that long time staffers
were losing their minds complaining that
she was like besmirching the
organization and charging his name
oh absolutely pr for that company yeah
yeah and they thought the controversy
was going to generate traffic or so this
is what i heard this from someone who
you know
had like behind the scenes access or
something like this
this is at washington post yeah okay
that the the long-standing employees of
the washington post like the older
people were like you are destroying the
legacy of this company
and that apparently there are people
there who thought that taylor lorenz was
going to generate traffic through like
controversy or stuff like that
i don't want to say anything that's
confirmed it's just rumor mill stuff
i've heard the same rumors right so
they're they're like they're
journalists and so i i wonder if the
washington post was like
these people are gonna quit on us and
then we have nothing so we gotta do
something
and so they demoted taylor lorenz and i
mean i think it i think i don't think
that's why they i think that they just
decided that she was a liability yeah i
think she should be careful
she was a liability people were like
there was a risk to the company i don't
think it was that it was a risk that
come i just think that they realize that
reliability is no no i think that they
realize that
she has no loyalty and that any any
controversy that she conjures
it's
often going to be at their expense
because she doesn't care about the brand
she just cares about herself and so
i don't think that they were worried
that people were going to quit i think
they were worried that
they that she was a beast that was about
to turn on them someone told me that
when we put up the billboard in times
square saying she docks libs of tick
tock that she immediately went and
demanded they file a suit or something
and like file a legal thing to get taken
down and they were like it's an opinion
statement you can't do anything about it
and she like lost it and then she went
on twitter and said it was so stupid and
laughable and then i responded with like
i responded to her and i was like i'm
glad you like i'm glad you think it's
funny great you got to say your thing i
say my thing and then she lost it she
blocked me and started screaming like
it's violence or whatever and i'm like
okay dude
whatever man
someone uh pointed out to me that
timkats.com has a higher credibility
rating
than cnn.com yeah that's amazing that's
true
that is in fact true look at that that's
kind of funny cnn's garbage so imagine
what we'd have if other stuff wasn't
going on thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there